all right so unless you've been living
under an actual rock
you'll probably have heard that ludwig
has become the most subscribed to
streamer in twitch history knocking
ninja off the top spot that he'd held
since 2018 and he did it by streaming
his entire life
for a month every meal every workout
every second including sleeping and
showering
for 716 hours straight
we're going to talk about what happened
because not only was it record-breaking
but at times it was fantastically insane
all right just before we jump into the
story i'm gonna remind you guys if you
haven't done so already
make sure you subscribe to the score
esports we are on the road to two
million subscribers and you can help us
get there all right so let's quickly run
down
who ludwig is before we talk about the
month that cemented him in the twitch
hall of fame
with the most subs of all time the 25
year old from new hampshire first made a
name for himself in the smash bros scene
even appearing
at evo 2017 and doing some commentary on
twitch he grew his stream by smashing
various
mario party world records in speed
running or
simply button mashing three quarters
one more is all we needed from last
time's attempt
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's the fastest masher in the
world he was likable
fun different and had a growing cult
following that would follow him to the
variety of different games he played
more recently he's rubbed shoulders with
some big twitch names while playing
trendy games like
among us or chess even with hikaru
himself
i would say in general terms of the
streamers i've seen you are one of the
top tier ones that i've seen by far
because the games you played like this
game there's
i mean the moves you played in the the
first
first 15 moves i mean i could not have
played better myself honestly it was
it was picture perfect that's too much
what are you no
i'm actually march 14th is the day our
story
really begins though the day ludwig
decided to do
a subathon subs add 20 seconds
for every sub tier 2 40 seconds tier 3
100 seconds bits it's equivalent 500
bits is 20 seconds
so on so forth the idea was simple
ludwig would continue to stay
live on twitch until the clock hit zero
every time someone subscribed the time
would increase by 20 seconds
and it was uncapped meaning as long as
the subs kept coming
he would keep streaming the clock time
increased quickly and ludwig went to
sleep on his first night in his now
infamous car bed
with 19 hours remaining naturally he
thought he'd wake up with
less time on the clock than before but
the donations and viewers kept pouring
in propelling ludwig to the most watched
streamer on twitch
while he slept it's through he's the
most
watched channel on twitch oh my god we
did it
we've got a sleeping man on twitch
we did it and then he woke up to find
that
the time hadn't gone down he now had 26
and a half
hours on the clock
as the stream gained more attention the
timer just kept going up
some people began to question ludwig's
motivations for the stream and whether
people should even be donating to him
as the clock approached 60 hours ludwig
addressed those concerns and also
why he started the whole subathon in the
first place
i think if i don't go live for 11 days
and i'm like gonna feel sad because my
sub counts lower because i've tied some
of my value to a number on a screen
that i want to do a subathon to
counteract that that's pretty normal
obviously i didn't plan for this as the
days rolled on
ludwig did literally everything on
stream
he played games he watched youtube and
movies with his viewers he
cooked for them had his hair cut by his
girlfriend he slept in front of his chat
while his mods talked
he even showered in front of them
isn't twitch [ __ ] weird the stream
was
intimate even if he was just sleeping it
felt like a sleepover with
thousands of people watching the clips
chatting about the stream
waiting for ludwig to wake up other
streamers have done subathons in the
past and streamed
every moment of their lives while
streamers like asian andy pioneered the
growing sleep stream format
we missed out on the best part by the
[Music]
way
so it's not like ludwig reinvented the
wheel here
he just put a big shiny rim on it even
the new york times picked up on the
story
now could another streamer have had as
much success with their subathon
possibly but watching ludwig over the
weeks it's clear that his
charm and his humor played a massive
part in all of this
i think if i push it back in and maybe
use the device
it might like go through a cycle
i didn't think about that after weeks of
constant live streaming
ludwig was leaping up the most
subscribed chart
only xqc's monstrous gta streams
seem to offer any real competition this
guy did 100 back to back
weeks are you serious how am i supposed
to get
number one for one [ __ ] week with
this psychopath
out here what is he doing got no life
got nothing to do just goes live for
[ __ ]
12 15 18 hours a day
get a hobby by now ludwig had brought
the time down from 20 to 10 seconds
for a sub and also banned anyone who
tried to gift more than a hundred subs
my problem people are spending too much
money and it's it's a bit uncomfortable
i want to curb the amount of money spent
at a 100 gift sub count
but ludwig would eventually be there for
a lot longer than seven days in fact
he wasn't even halfway through yet as
the subs poured in he realized there
needed to be
some sort of absolute hard limit put
on the stream's length and for him that
was 31 days
the 31 day cap is in place uh it's
it's not really a cap it's more so that
i said multiple times if i hit 31 days i
would break ninja's record for the most
subs ever all time on twitch
and if i ever hit that record then
i i mean like i don't i don't see it you
know
it could just repeat i guess but i i
don't care to do that
so now we had a definite end point but
it could still have ended before that
if the clock hit zero and it came very
close
at one point reaching just four seconds
remaining
before being saved now while all this
was going on people began to discuss
just how much money was ludwig making
from this stream
after a little under two weeks live he
pulled up a spreadsheet to calculate his
earnings up to that point which resulted
in an estimated total of 470
thousand dollars but ludwig showed that
after
charity taxes and paying his mods he'd
only see a fraction of that
i said i would donate a dollar for every
single subscriber i had
i have received about 80 000 subscribers
which means after including charity
i got three thousand dollars at one
point the clock even got
to one second before chat decided
to make sure the record would be broken
but the finish line was now in sight
ludwig announced he would be ending the
stream on april
13th if the clock hadn't hit zero by
that point
and also upping his charity donations to
five dollars per sub
and just as ludwig predicted on april
13th
he finally surpassed ninja's long-held
record as the most subscribed streamer
on twitch he even called the real ninja
himself to share the news
definitely the real ninja i just broke
your record what the [ __ ] you say to me
you little [ __ ]
i i just i just i just broke you
i no i i'm not saying i'm big time it's
not like i'm
leonardo dicaprio i'm just saying that i
just broke the record i'm my brother
leonardo
you're trash okay
ludwig's number is still fluctuating but
he tweeted out soon after
to show the world that he'd surpassed
ninja's record
of 269 154 subs
it can't be understated just how big of
an achievement this really was
ninja had held the record since 2018 and
achieved it from some insanely big
streams playing
fortnite with the likes of drake and
travis scott and a lot of people thought
well
that must be the way to do it if you
want to get to the absolute top of
twitch
you've gotta play games with massive
celebrities
or you know floss dance in times square
i'm not sure how many of you guys
remember that era but fortnight felt
like it was the biggest thing on planet
earth and
ninja wasn't too far behind that the
record felt
insurmountable and then ludwig comes
along years later and
breaks the record by doing the most
normal things that his viewers also do
he ate he slept he played games and this
appeal to a more casual kind of stream
is reflected
in the massive growth of the just
chatting category on twitch
just chatting has dominated twitch over
the last two years
a platform which was specifically
created to cater to the gaming community
and ludwig's subathon could not
represent just chatting more
it was like just chatting on steroids
chilling out
eating and sleeping on stream except for
an entire month but those things in
themselves aren't unique it was the
unique nature of the subathon that
captivated viewers
people felt invested in this spectacle
of perpetual
normality and the excitement of reaching
a goal with him
the most subscribed to channel on twitch
of
all time and this sense of real
involvement was seen
most clearly when ludwig's viewers
seemed to split
into two different groups those who
wanted to free ludwig
and those who just wanted the stream to
never end but it had to end
at some point ludwig knew that more than
anyone and so
after celebrating his new position at
the top of twitch in front of almost a
quarter of a million viewers
the timer finally hit zero and there was
no stopping it this time what's next
what do you do after that
well ludwig has categorically said that
he is
never doing a subathon ever again and
you can't blame him
and the reason i would never do one
again is very simple
and it's the reason why you shouldn't
make a sequel to the movie the hangover
it'll never be as good as the original
how the
am i gonna top something that happened
like magically out of the blue
for a planned 24-hour stream that ended
up going a month
breaking records and also
getting new york times articles by just
saying i'm gonna do the same thing again
bad ludwig wasn't a small streamer
before this by any means but
now he's cemented himself as one of the
biggest streamers on twitch
like ever as for how much money he made
only ludwig really knows but his mods
walked away with some cash
one of them sharing that the money had
allowed them to pay off their credit
card debt completely
how long will he hold the record for who
knows but for now
ludwig has got what he wanted he's
number one
he pulled off an insane month-long
subathon
and now he's just finally happy to call
it a day
this is what the end of the subathon was
supposed to look like
but i faded it to black because i was on
the verge of
tears because i was so emotional so
overwhelmed with the motion
i don't get too mushy in this [ __ ] but
i think i was just emotional because uh
it was it was a goal achieved
it was a goal achieved that was exciting
it was exciting to achieve a goal i've
been working towards
as well as understanding that this will
one day go away
and that makes me sad when i think about
that because i like it so much
i like it so much i love streaming so
much that when one day i won't stream
i will be sad uh but that's okay
i can enjoy it for what it is now
um yeah i'm going to do a 30 31 day
subathon
but it's basically um i'm going to keep
working
just just working on the channel um like
normal
so it's just going to be a webcam of
watching me typing
yeah it's gonna be me talking about
other streamers and their streams
um you know and then lots of lots of you
know exciting content of me
unplugging microphones plugging in
cameras getting frustrated with cables
what a stream i'm boring myself just
talking about it
that's what's going on let's get into it
let's get into this [ __ ] guys
like all you guys do so cool
and i'm like i'm like the fantastical mr
ludwig's sake